basta Machtwort oder
Richtlinienkompetenz wie auch immer man
es nennen möchte der Kanzler hat klare
Kante gezeigt und per Brief seinen
zerstrittenen Ministern einen Weg im AKW
Zank angewiesen zwei statt drei
Kernkraftwerke sollen bis April laufen
aber es sollen keine neuen Brennstäbe
angeschafft werden habeg und Lindner
wollten jeweils etwas anderes loben aber
den kanzlerkompromiss gesichtswarend als
guten Weg aus der verfahrenen Situation
warum dann eigentlich nicht gleich so
denn FDP grün und SPD ihr hattet doch
eine Koalition auf Augenhöhe versprochen
das Machtwort bringt Scholz die Ampel
wieder auf Kurs unser Thema in der
Phönix runter
Phoenix Runde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin ich darf hier meine Gäste
vorstellen ich begrüße Ulrike Herrmann
wirtschaftsredakteurin der taz und auch
Buchautorin und gerade erschienen das
Ende des Kapitalismus und ich begrüße
herzlich Frank am Meyer er ist
Journalist aus der Schweiz lebt schon
lange in Berlin Kolumnist für Cicero
fOCUS Online und den schweizerischen
SonntagsBlick herzlich willkommen
Wolfgang Schröder Professor für
Politikwissenschaft an der Universität
Kassel er war auch mal Staatssekretär im
Ministerium für Arbeit Soziales Frauen
und Familie des Landes Brandenburg und
ist Mitglied der Grundwerte Kommission
der SPD und herzlich willkommen Prof
Stephan kurz er ist Ökonom und
Vizepräsident des Kieler Instituts für
Weltwirtschaft Frau Hermann ein
Machtwort ja heißt es alle Male alle
sagen der Kanzler hat jetzt mal
durchgegriffen Führung gezeigt hat sie
das überrascht
nee weil es ist ja ganz klar dass
Scholz eigentlich ähnlich führt wie
vorher auch Merkel also er führt von
hinten nicht von vorne also ist nicht so
dass er gleich sagt und hier geht es
lang und dann guckt ob alle hinter ihm
hier marschieren und dann kann er dann
gucken dass alle sagen nie nee will ich
nicht sondern stattdessen macht er es so
dass er erstmal guckt wo die Mehrheiten
sind auch in der Bevölkerung auch in
seiner Partei und wenn er dann lange
genug zugeguckt hat und weiß wo es lang
gehen kann mit allgemeiner Zustimmung
dann entscheidet er aber die
Richtlinienkompetenz hat Angela Merkel
nicht so gezogen wie er jetzt nee das
stimmt jetzt muss man natürlich sagen
dass Angela Merkel auch nicht in einer
Ampel war und die Situation mit diesen
drei Parteien ist tatsächlich extrem
schwierig weil die FDP ja eine
Wahlniederlage nach der nächsten ein
kassiert also entweder fliegen sie ganz
raus aus den Parlamenten oder aber Sie
müssen erleben dass sie nicht mehr in
den Landesregierungen vertreten sind die
Umfragen sind mau das heißt es geht um
die Existenz und jetzt muss die FDP die
ganze Zeit da Remmidemmi machen um zu
profilieren auf der anderen Seite müssen
natürlich auch die Grünen irgendwie
gucken dass sie sichtbar sind und mit
diesen beiden Parteien ist es dann
schwierig und das muss dann stolz am
Ende austarieren aber vielleicht letzter
Satz das ist eine dankbare Rolle okay da
kommen wir gleich noch mal wir gucken
noch mal auf Scholz Roll endlich etwas
genauer noch Herr Meyer waren sie
überrascht dann der Kanzler hat ja mal
gesagt der Führung will haben will sie
bestellt der kriegt sie auch von mir
also das ganze überhaupt ganz anders
wir haben ja seit 1959 eine Regierung
mit vier Parteien immer die gleichen und
haben dieses wir haben keinen Kanzler
sind alle gleich die Minister und wir
haben dieses aus ja in der Schweiz
natürlich dieses ausdiskutieren der
Sache innerhalb der Regierung ist bei
uns eine Übung und die ist sehr alt
diese Übung und die funktioniert und das
was die Ampel macht ist jetzt eigentlich
ein Stück auf dem Weg zu Schweiz das
sind plötzlich drei drei Parteien in der
Regierung und diskutieren es gab meiner
Meinung nach überhaupt kein Machtwort
das war alles vorgesehen die Grünen
sollen zufrieden sein mit dem was der
habe ich will und dann sagen die es war
einvernehmlich dann machen wir das so
der Kanzler Scholz sagt jawohl die
laufen jetzt bis nächsten Frühjahr und
ich bin überzeugt wenn der Winter
irgendwie ganz stramm wird dann werden
die sich auch verständigen sagen müssen
wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen länger
warten immer alles so direkt das ist die
alte deutsche Übung das geht viel
indirekte das ist so eine eine es ist
eigentlich dass Direktorium das ist die
letzte Regierungsform gewesen dass
Direktorium der französischen Mann
diskutiert die Dinge man suchten Kondens
hier wird das drapiert mit einem
Machtwort weil es ein Kanzler gibt wegen
Direktorium gab es auch keinen der
mehr als der andere und bei uns auch
nicht ich glaube der Weg ist sehr gut
man gewöhnt sich an eine Kultur in der
drei Parteien miteinander können auch
wenn sie Entschuldigung auch wenn Sie
ein Konflikt haben dass ihr gebunden man
kann miteinander wenn man Konflikt hat
wenn man keinen Konflikt hat muss
niemand miteinander können dann geht
sowieso Herr Schröder sind sie zufrieden
damit und hätten sie es erwartet na ich
hätte mir zunächst mal gewünscht dass
das alles schon viel früher geregelt
wird weil es ja wirklich um die
Energieversorgung um die wirtschaftliche
Basis des Landes geht insofern würde ich
mal sagen dass der Kompromiss der jetzt
hergestellt worden ist relativ spät
gekommen ist aber wie Frau Hermann schon
sagte dass entspricht dem
führungs- bzw
Moderationsstil von Scholz der von
hinten die Dinge bedenkt und der ja auch
weiß wir leben hier nicht in einer
Hierarchie in einem Königreich sondern
er kann nur vermitteln er kann
integrieren er kann Krisenmanagement und
interessant ist ja diese Entscheidung
findet statt nach der niedersachsenwahl
sie findet statt nach dem Parteitag der
Grünen da ist also ein Fenster
aufgemacht worden an dem er zuhauen
konnte und eine neue Lage entwickelt
dann das Interessante ist ja alle
Parteien die daran involviert sind in
der Spitzenlage sind ja sehr zufrieden
insofern hat man eine Win-Win-Situation
und das ist etwas was in der Politik
selten vorkommt und was auch nicht lange
halten wird also ein Kompromiss ist ein
guter Kompromiss weil nachher alle sagen
ist doch in Ordnung so macht das denn
auch energiepolitisch Sinn was da
beschlossen worden ist ja also sehe ich
zunächst erstmal nicht zu entscheiden
war gar keine Option denn es war eine
zeitkritische Frage und die muss die
jetzt auf dem letzten Drücker
entschieden werden ich würde sagen mit
dieser Entscheidung hat Scholz jetzt die
Regierung erstmal aus einer Sackgasse
geführt aber sie ist noch nicht wieder
in der Spur zu dieser Spur angehören
dass man eine neue energiepolitische
Strategie entwickelt jetzt wo russisches
Gas als Brücken Energieträger für die
Energiewende weggefallen ist und darüber
hat man sich noch gar nicht verständigt
und deshalb ist das akute Thema erstmal
abgeräumt aber die Frage wie die
Energiepolitik in diesem Jahr in diesem
Land aussehen soll in den nächsten
Jahren die steht weiter noch aus die
Grünen haben ja gesagt es ist gar nicht
nötig dass das AKW in Emsland dass das
überhaupt ans Netz geht das macht
eigentlich gar keinen Sinn also diese
Frage ist ohnehin eine Petitesse wir
haben jetzt jahrzehntelang hier
Atomenergie im Land gehabt und ob wir
jetzt ein spezifisches oder ein
bestimmtes Atomkraftwerk im
streckbetrieb noch mal dreieinhalb
Monate länger betreiben oder nicht das
wird aufgebauscht zu einer Frage von
Wohl und Wehe das ist wirklich eine
völlige Marginalie die tut gar nicht zur
Sache aber worum ging es denn dann
ja also wo ich jetzt erstmal Hand kurz
zustimmen muss ist tatsächlich hätte man
dieses Lingen Kraftwerk nicht gebraucht
weil im Norden ist genug Strom da und
dieser Strom kommt auch nicht in den
Süden weil die Leitungen fehlen das war
also reine Symbolpolitik und das ging
tatsächlich darum dass die FDP sich
profilieren kann also wie gesagt die hat
ja vier Landtagswahlen verloren jetzt
musste sie irgendwie zeigen dass sie
noch da ist und wahrscheinlich ist das
eine vielkalkulation also ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass die FDP Wähler die
FDP wählen wegen der Atompolitik das
scheint aber Lindner nicht zu verstehen
er denkt der kann da sich irgendwie als
Opposition in der Regierung profilieren
als sozusagen sichtbares anderes und
das wäre jetzt auch auf diese Atomfrage
so abfährt liegt auch daran dass das FDP
Wahlprogramm außerordentlich
inhaltsschwach war also ich habe das
ganze die ganzen Seiten gelesen da stand
eigentlich nur drin Steuersenkung für
die Reichen und Schuldenbremse beides
kommt nicht jetzt haben sie aber keine
anderen Programmpunkte also musste er
sich irgendwie auf die at aber er wollte
ja dass die Atomkraftwerke bis 2024
laufen ja genau aus diesem Grund weil er
einfach nichts anderes hat außer dann
hat er doch jetzt klar verloren
eigentlich wollte auch also das ist muss
man sagen der Verlierer in der ganzen
Debatte ist in der Tat Lindner er selber
sagt aber nee ich bin gar kein Verlierer
weil ich habe ja jetzt das AKW im
Emsland noch zusätzlich an die Leitungen
gekriegt obwohl es nichts bringt aber
faktisch muss man tatsächlich sagen ja
er ist der Verlierer und das mit dem
Atomthema sollte eigentlich
perspektivisch lassen
steht jetzt noch mal kann man noch mal
gesondert diskutieren aber insgesamt ist
das natürlich von der Fragestellung die
beantwortet werden muss
energiepolitisches Strategie ist sind
jetzt diese dreieinhalb Monate die sind
nun wirklich nicht belangvoll und
deshalb wundert mich auch dass alles so
zufrieden sind denn eigentlich hatten
sich ja nur darüber verständigt worüber
man sich nicht verständigen kann und die
Antworten müssen weiterhin gegeben
werden und die werden unangen werden
dieser Konstellation herr Meyer sie
kennt Christian Lindner gut sind
befreundet mit ihm würden sie das auch
so sehen dass er da Verlierer ist
natürlich nicht
Frau Hellmann lacht und zieht so weil
sie grün ist ist eine Zuordnung die man
machen kann damit das alles schon um die
Hälfte ist qualifiziert und bei mir
durch den Freund ich Verteidiger also
den Freund sie die Grünen sie machen ja
Wahlkampf jetzt und es ist anderes als
nichts anderes als eine bärchenkampagne
gegen die gegen die Freisinnigen wie sie
nenne aus der schweizerischen Tradition
und ich finde
es war einfach die Verweigerung nicht
die Verweigerung des Ausstiegs aus der
Atomwirtschaft das haben die nicht
bestrittenen
und zu Vernunft gehört dass man es
wahrscheinlich weiterführen kann wenn es
nötig ist noch bis ins Jahr 24 bin
übrigens damit das auch ganz klar ist
nicht bin fast grün bin nämlich gegen
die Atomwirtschaft also war ich schon
vor 20 Jahren also das ist meine Haltung
aber es ist unvernünftig solche
ideologischen Positionen auf Teufel
kommen raus zu verteidigen in ich glaube
eben dass im Grunde genommen eine
Regierung auch ein Stück Freiheit derer
ist die drin sind sie lösen sich von
ihren Parteien sie können viel
beweglicher dem zustimmen dieser Sache
zustimmen weil die Vernunft hält Einzug
in Besonderheit bei Leuten die aus
Parteien kommen die eigentlich eher
religiöse Bewegungen
die Atomkraftwerke und zwar alle drei
bis 24 weiterlaufen zu lassen und das
das passiert ja nicht und es ist auch
ganz klar das soll den neuen Brennstäbe
gekauft werden und überhaupt wird der
Ausstieg aus der Atomkraft noch mal klar
besiegelt am 15 April 23 also dann ist
es doch eine Niederlage für Christian
Lindner habt etwas dran gegeben so wie
die Grünen was dran gegeben haben und so
wird sich das in anderen Sachen
Verhalten dies ist das ganz normale
Handwerk des Regierens wenn drei
Parteien sind bei 4 wird es noch
schwieriger aber ist eine tolle Übung
nur drei Parteien hatten wir vorher auch
schon wenn wir die CSU mitrechnet die
hat so viel trouble in der Regierung
gemacht dass die Transitionen schon fast
sagen
aber ich glaube mit dem Begriff der
Vernunft kommt man hier nicht viel
weiter die Parteien und die Gliederungen
der Parteien also die Gruppen die die
Parteien die haben Interessen die haben
Ideen und die können natürlich darauf
bestehen dass diese Ideen auch wirkt
mächtig werden wenn ich also grüner wäre
und diese Partei ist maßgeblich durch
den Atomkonflikt groß geworden ohne den
Atomkonflikt kann man die Grünen
überhaupt zu verstehen und das ist da
einzelne Gruppen Personen Landesverbände
gibt die sagen darauf investieren wir
und wenn dann gleichzeitig die FDP und
die CDU kommt in Eindruck erweckt dass
es nicht um eine temporäre Streckung
geht sondern möglicherweise um den
Ausstieg vom Ausstieg dann kann man sich
durchaus vorstellen dass es Leute
innerhalb der Grünen gibt die sagen das
machen wir nicht mit zumal ja die
energiepolitische Gewissheit das daran
das Schicksal Deutschlands hängt gar
nicht so klar ist wenn man die Experten
hört und das sollte man durchaus mit
berücksichtigen wenn man eine Bewertung
der Positionen und Kandidaten von dann
wieder spreche ich doch gar nicht ist
völlig richtig dass die Grünen für ihre
Sachen kämpfen und zwar ganz neben dem
Begriff der verloren
denn das gibt's das gibt's tatsächlich
man lernt in der Regel man lernt wir
haben ein ganz interessantes Phänomen
seit der
corona-pandemie und jetzt mit dem Krieg
in der Ukraine und wir haben zum ersten
Mal eine Situation dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger nicht weiter sind als die
Politiker respektive die Politiker nicht
weiter sind in der Erkenntnis als die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger man tastet sich
vor man lernt und diese Regierung lernt
das ist eine Lehre Regierung ob man sich
das leisten kann also in der
Energiepolitik ob man die Zeit hat
sozusagen stimmen wenn ich auch also wir
reden ja hier über die Energiepolitik
des viertgrößten Industrielandes der
Welt und da geht es vielleicht um ein
bisschen mehr als um die Gesichtswahrung
das kann man sicher bei
Nebensächlichkeiten dann mal als
Scharmützel gönnen aber hier braucht es
eigentlich schon eine Regierung die ein
gemeinsames Fundament hat und das hat
sie augenscheinlich nicht und deshalb
ist meine Prognose stehen ihr noch sehr
schwierige Monate bevor beziehungsweise
die Regierung hat das Fundament aber sie
muss die anderen mitnehmen und insofern
war
die jeweiligen Gruppen in den Parteien
die abweichende Position haben
eigentlich sehr stark bewegt für ihre
unglaublich bewegt also wenn man deren
Haltung zu Kohle zu Atom sieht zu Waffen
das ist die Partei die sich am stärksten
neuer Regierung bewegt hat ausgehend von
den Positionen die sie ursprünglich
mitgebracht hat und gleichzeitig wird
das Gute regieren ja nur funktionieren
wenn am Ende auch im Parlament die
Mehrheiten zustande kommen insofern hat
Harbeck natürlich gestern Abend schon
was richtiges gesagt um Scholz da auch
eine gewisse erbung entgegenzubringen
das ist ein Risiko für Scholz ist also
so ganz ohne Risiko geht es nicht aber
sie haben natürlich Recht unter normalen
Zeiten wäre das alles toll wie das
gerade oder wie im Lehrbuch aber wir
haben keine normalen Zeit aber das ist
übrigens ein wichtiger Punkt den Herr
Schröder der anspricht dass das ganze ja
noch durchs Parlament gehen muss und
dass das natürlich auch zeigt dass
Scholz da jetzt kein Machtwort
gesprochen hat sondern er hat eigentlich
das gesagt wofür es dann tatsächlich in
seiner Koalition Minderheiten gibt denn
das muss ja alles dann durch die Angst
sicher die Fraktionsführung von von Grün
und FDP haben ja schon gesagt dass Sie
dem zustimmen also da scheint jetzt
wahrscheinlich oder auch mehr aber auch
keine großen Zweifel nur dass ein
Kanzler nach gerade mal einem Jahr
Regierungszeit schon die
Richtlinienkompetenz ziehen muss das ist
natürlich auch ein Zeichen ist ein sehr
scharfes Schwert aber je öfter man ist
sieht desto stumpfer wird ist oder ist
das glaube ich diese Richtlinien weiter
das was hier passiert sind doch
Verhandlungen sind permanent verhandelt
die haben in der letzten Woche dreimal
zusammengesetzt die sind ja warum haben
sie das nicht so geschafft warum muss er
da diesen Brief schreiben am Ende dann
doch innerhalb des Prozederes abläuft
was die Verfassung einerseits
ermöglichen andererseits die
Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages und in diesem Sinne ist das
dann schon ein gelungener
Verhandlungsprozess wo am Ende
zumindestens eine kleine Atempause ist
insofern hat man sich ja nur Zeit
bekommen da steht weil dann Scholz
sozusagen als also weil nein ich glaube
diese Richtlinienkompetenz wurde dann am
Ende genutzt obwohl tatsächlich
permanent verhandelt wurde weil das
allen Beteiligten die Möglichkeit
gegeben hat ihr Gesicht zu wahren nicht
also Schadeck konnte seiner Basis sagen
tut mir leid der Kanzler hat jetzt
gesagt das ist der Kompromiss Lindner
konnte sagen ja ja das ist jetzt der
Kompromiss aber ich habe ja ganz viel
rausgeholt und Scholz ist steht da jetzt
als Macher da ist eigentlich für alle
drei super und deswegen haben sie das
auf diese Weise inszeniert
okay ist die Ampel jetzt stärker seitdem
herr Meier oder ist sie schwächer
ich würde sagen die Ampel entwickelt
sich zu einer Regierung die durchhält
oder auseinander fällt das ist nicht
festzustellen aber es ist ein Experiment
ja es ist ein Moment es ist ein ein ganz
wichtiges Leben nicht wie cdu/csu das
geht nicht es ist ein Experiment in
Deutschland
tierens durch dass man verhandelt dass
man im Grunde genommen weil man Kanzler
hat gibt es das aber eine Regierung die
das nicht hat hätte die gibt's ja von
dieser Erfahrung rede ich die diskutiert
bis sie ungefähr dort ist wo sie sagen
kann okay so machen wir es und das war
auch diesmal der Fall am man hat es dann
drapiert quasi mit dem mit dem mit der
Richtlinien ja genau es war auch
irgendwie
Journalisten hatten wieder was zu
berichten die Regierung fällt sie
auseinander tun wir ja jetzt ist ja
wunderbar unser Mädchen gell also wir
wollen uns
ist das nicht ein gutes ja wenn sie
sagen Experiment in der Zeit die eine
solch starke Krise hat also kann man
sich das erlauben ist das Gegenüber
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern das richtige
dass man sagt man man kann man schafft
es nicht vorher eine klare Linie zu
finden so haben die Bürger Gebirge
gewählt aber ich glaube das ich meine
das erinnert auch so ein bisschen an
Tarifverhandlungen da muss auch immer
nachts verhandelt werden und bis auf den
letzten Drücker damit dann alle das
Gefühl haben jeder hat gekämpft und so
lief das jetzt hier auch aber Herr kurz
hat natürlich recht dass das
basisproblem nicht gelöst ist also die
das Gas aus Russland sollte die
Brückentechnologie sein auf dem Weg in
die erneuerbare Zukunft mit
Solarpaneelen und Windrädern so und
jetzt ist dieses Gas weg nicht und die
Atomkraft ist dafür kein Ersatz aus
verschiedensten Gründen aber unter
anderem weil das ja Grundlast ist und
nicht auf die flexible
Windlage reagieren kann so und dann ist
sie wirklich die Frage was macht man
jetzt ja und ehrlich gesagt er wird ja
noch nicht mal die Frage gestellt
es gäbe jetzt einen Hebel den man
umlegen muss und dann sein alle Probleme
gelöst die Atomkraft kann nicht alle
Probleme lösen aber sie kann natürlich
einen Baustein in einer Gesamtlösung
sein
derzeit strapazieren wir ja stärker die
Kohlekraftwerke das bedeutet aber auch
wir brauchen jetzt CO2 Zertifikate
freuen sich unsere Nachbarn auch nicht
drüber weil wir den vereinbarten Sockel
jetzt schneller abschmelzen das heißt
auch da wird ein Problem eigentlich in
die Zukunft verschoben weil wir müssen
dann in der Zukunft umso stärkere
ja Einsparungen hinlegen in der
Zwischenzeit steigen dann auch eher die
CO2-Preise dadurch das ist also nicht so
mit man die übrigen europäischen
Nachbarn besonders beglückt und es fehlt
eben die strategische Ansage die muss in
Richtung langfristige Lieferverträge für
LNG laufen das ist sicherlich eine
Komponente es kann auch beinhalten die
heimische Förderung auszubauen von
Erdgas wäre dann also im Wesentlichen
Fracking oder eben auch die Atomenergie
dann aber auch nicht bis 2004 die Reden
über 2024 wir reden über eine
Brückentechnologie für den
Übergangsprozess der Energiewende also
wir reden eher über 15 Jahren als über
Jahre deshalb war dieser Vorschlag bis
2024 ohnehin schon zu kurz gegriffen ich
würde gerne einen anderen Punkt machen
und zwar man könnte diesen gelungenen
Prozess wenn man es mal so festhalten
will dann als gelungen verstehen wenn
sich daraus nicht nur gekaufte Zeit und
eine gewisse Beruhigung ergibt sondern
sowas in ihrem Sinne ein Lernprozess man
sagt also wir können uns das eigentlich
nicht mehr erlauben dass wir in diesen
kleinteiligen Fragen und so verstricken
und dabei die große Dimension der
Energiepolitik der Versorgung nicht nur
in Deutschland sondern auch in Europa
mit berücksichtigen und wenn das gelänge
wäre ja die Möglichkeit dass man als
nächstes in diesem Meer ebenensystem die
europäische Ebene weil die ganze
Energiepolitik hat eine zutiefst
europäische eben das Worst Case Szenario
wäre natürlich auch nicht ausgeschlossen
dass das nur das Vorspiel eines
immerwährenden krisenprozesses ist um
diesen Laden zusammenzuhalten und dann
wäre dieser Kanzler keiner der die
langen Linien im positiven Sinne
beeinflussen könnte sondern er wäre
wirklich nur der krisenmoderator der
hinter den Krisen herläuft nun aber ich
glaube dass man also das ist natürlich
jetzt reine Spekulation aber ich nehme
mal an dass in der Regierung die
heimliche Hoffnung ist dass diese
Ukraine Krieg demnächst zu Ende geht
also spätestens im nächsten Frühjahr
ganz einfach weil die russische
lagestrategisch auswegslos ist die
Russen können diesen Krieg nicht mehr
gewinnen und dann hofft man natürlich
dass sie das irgendwann auch einsehen
und dann das russische Gas auch wieder
läuft und die ehrlich gesagt halte ich
für diese Hoffnung dass in sagen wir mal
in sechs Monaten wieder Gas aus Russland
kommt nicht für völlig abwegig und das
ist glaube ich aber nicht auf dem
Prinzip Hoffnung gucken
könnten sie sich ein vorstellen dass
wenn es jetzt diesen Winter wirklich
ganz schwierig wird mit und wenn man
dann überlegt 2024 haben wir dann keinen
Gas mehr aus Russland dass die Grünen
sich dann doch weiter bewegen würden das
ist dann auf einmal heißt ja jetzt
kaufen wir doch ein paar neue Brennstäbe
ja also das ja das hat eben zwei
Probleme das eine ist dass die Atomkraft
tatsächlich sehr schwierig ist als
Technik weil es Grundlast ist die ist
wenn man die einmal anstellt den läuft
immer durch das heißt Wind aber dann
wird die Windenergie aus dem Netz
gedrängt das wird jetzt auch im Norden
passieren weil Lingen jetzt wieder ins
Netz geht und das zweite ist dass auch
die Uran Brennstäbe kommen jetzt zu
einem großen Teil aus Russland und wenn
man jetzt die gesamten Atomkraftwerke in
Westeuropa anguckt dann hängen die zu
einem großen Teil an diesen Uran
Lieferungen aus Russland und das kann
Westinghouse in den USA nicht komplett
kompensieren das heißt man sitzt dann
wieder in der Abhängigkeit und das ist
also wie man jetzt von es gibt
eigentlich nur einen Weg von Russland
unabhängig zu werden und das wäre die
Erneuerbaren Technologien wirklich sehr
schnell sehr stark auszubauen
dahinter steht dass man bis zum 15 April
dieses Projekt auslaufen lässt und hofft
dass man in der Zwischenzeit auch mit
offshore und anderen Formen in der
regenerativen Energie weiter kommt das
ist doch ein Tropfen auf den heißen
Stein was sie bis zu Mitte April an
erneuerbaren Energien ausbauen abgesehen
davon brauchen Sie dafür ja auch immer
noch entweder irgendwelche Speicher oder
eben Kraftwerke diese dann zuschalten
können aber selbst wenn sie können ist
gar nicht so beschleunigen dass die die
Gaskraftwerke dadurch überflüssig machen
das ist völlig ausgeschlossen und man
muss hier schon Politik mit Augenmaß
machen und da wäre die Atome nicht also
wenn wir auch hier müssen natürlich dann
Entscheidungen treffen da können wenn
wir das immer noch alle drei Monate auch
Wiedervorlage legen dann wird es
natürlich umso schwerer beispielsweise
die Beschaffung von Brennstäben zu
sichern nämlich jetzt die Frage muss man
schon ein bisschen mehr Perspektive
entwickeln ob man es immer auf
Wiedervorlage liegt und was das jetzt
bedeutet also wenn man jetzt sagt man
hat sich jetzt geeinigt wie lange denken
Sie einmal hält dieser Kompromiss oder
kommt da schon das nächste um die Ecke
und die FDP hat wahrscheinlich auch
Angst denn wenn bei so einem
Herzensprojekt wie der Atomkraft bei den
Grünen wenn der wenn der Kanzler da
klare Linie zieht das vielleicht dann
bei der Schuldenbremse auch mal die
Richtlinienkompetenz gezogen wird diese
Regierung ist ja ein ganz anderes geht
ja nicht nur darum Atomkraftwerke es
geht um eine Strategie des Ausstiegs aus
Abhängigkeiten die Abhängigkeit von
China ist wirtschaftlich wesentlich
größer und im Vergleich zu
China ist ja Russland eine
halbdemokratie also da kann man ja sagen
das ist ja die totale
die totale digitale Diktatur die Bilder
müssen wir nur anschauen von gestern da
brauchen wir nichts zu hören was die
sagen wir müssen nur die Bilder sehen
dann wissen Sie wer nicht ein Rivale ist
das fällt er den deutschen schwer jetzt
bringe ich ein Wort das den deutschen
schwer fällt es ist ein Feind und wir
haben eine Strategie zu fahren dass man
aus diesen Abhängigkeiten rauskommt und
das wird sich in nächsten drei Jahren
Vorentscheiden das kann man nicht
entscheiden die nächsten drei Jahren und
das geht weiter über das Gas aus
Russland hinaus das muss die Aufgabe
dieser Regierung sein und ist das gerade
auch deine Stärke weil es eben eine
Regierung aus drei sehr
unterschiedlichen Parteien ist dann
können Sie es zu Stärke machen indem die
die Grünen sind ja eine ganz elementar
wichtige Bewegung die uns Bewusstsein
schafft wie wie früher die Kommunisten
in der sozialfrage man kann das sagen
auch religiös grundiert wie damals die
kommen jetzt aber wichtig elementar
wichtig und die zu integrieren in diesem
strategischen Prozess bei Schröder war
das nicht so da waren man sagt immer auf
Schweizerdeutsch
einfach da wurde fortgeschrieben wenn
auch nicht nicht dumm aber jetzt ist das
was anderes und das Spielen die Grünen
eine ganz essentielle Rolle und die rein
zu nehmen das doch eine tolle Geschichte
also sind sie ja auch begonnen es ist ja
wir machen eine Koalition eben auf
Augenhöhe dieser andere Stil auch gerade
Grüne und FDP zusammen Herr Schröder ist
da wie viel ist da noch von übrig jetzt
auch ja nach diesem Machtwort oder wie
auch immer man es nennt also ich würde
diese Entwicklung der letzten Tage eher
als eine Bestätigung dafür sehen dass
wir nicht in einer Kanzler Demokratie
leben sondern in einer
verhandlungsdemokratie und dass diese
verhandlungsdemokratie das Potenzial zum
Lernen hat und das ist ein Stück weit
natürlich auch ein Imperativ weil
einfach das ist ja hier sehr schöne
herausgearbeitet und der Druck so
elementar ist unabhängiger Wert zu
werden souveräner zu werden unabhängiger
von Russland unabhängiger von China und
mehr Europa das ist glaube ich
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz sagt
dann habe ich hat eine schallende
Ohrfeige bekommen und Lindner ist
politisch stark beschädigt durch
muss er sagen um weiterhin sein Gehalt
als Oppositionsführer zu bekommen das
ist kein besonders
geistreicher Beitrag zur Debatte sondern
das ist das was er machen muss okay wo
wären denn wo sehen Sie die nächsten
Baustellen vorher Hermann wenn man ich
habe die Schuldenbremse schon
angesprochen also wo gibt es wieder noch
mehr Konfliktpotenzial wo man sagen
könnte oh da kann es noch mal richtig
krachen also ich glaube die nächste
unmittelbare Krise die dann wieder
auftauchen wird ist Corona weil die
Zahlen gehen ja durch die Decke und die
FDP hat sich ja so als
corona-freiheitspartei inszeniert bloß
keine Masken und so weiter also man
wollte da ja letztlich doch Wähler von
der AFD zurückbekommen zu FDP so dieser
Kurs wird jetzt aber schwierig wenn das
mit Corona immer
katastrophaler wird so da glaube ich
kommt dann die nächste Krise wo sich
alle wieder profilieren werden und dann
das andere Problem ist natürlich es
hängt jetzt eigentlich
mit dem ukrainekrieg zusammen dass wir
ja auf eine Rezession zusteuern auch das
wird dann wahrscheinlich noch mal zu
Spannungen führen wie man das jetzt
angehen soll konkret auch da wird ja auf
Sicht Gefahren bei dem Thema Rezession
und legen da ist ja auch die EU-Politik
also wir haben die Euro-Krise ja bislang
über die Notenbank vor uns hergewälzt
und da hat man sich im Koalitionsvertrag
ein sehr schlanken Fuß gemacht da steht
ein Satz dazu drin das bedeutet das hat
man einfach ausgeklammert und hofft dass
sie nicht die roulent wird aber wir
gehen jetzt auch aufgrund der
Energiekrise natürlich auch sehr schwer
und ökonomischen Zeiten in der
Europäischen Union entgegen wir haben
historisch hohe Schuldenstände und die
Inflation hat stark angezogen übrigens
auch die heimische Komponente der
Inflation es ist eben nicht nur eine
energie-story sondern die Notenbank muss
jetzt hier deutlich auf die Bremse
treten und das macht natürlich die
Situation viel schwieriger als man sie
sich jetzt zehn Jahre lang gemacht hat
in dem einfach die Notenbank den
Regierungen ja gewissermaßen den Rücken
freigehalten hat was sie nicht hätte tun
sollen denn jetzt sind die Probleme umso
größer und die alten Rezepte die
Notenbank parkt die hohen
Schuldenstände irgendwie heraushält die
Zinsen niedrig und hat damit das Problem
vertagt das funktioniert so nicht mehr
bzw Situation was heißt das denn für den
Bundesfinanzminister Oma bei den drei
Herren noch mal zu bleiben ja das jetzt
wahrscheinlich noch stärkere
Anforderungen kommen die Schulden Last
auf EU-Ebene zu vergemeinschaften das
wird auch in einer bestimmten Weise
notwendig sein diese
Überschuldungssituation für skatisch zu
lösen das bedeutet neuerliche Lasten und
ob man darauf verständigen kann
scheint mir doch sehr fraglich zu sein
wie würden sie es denn ich glaube dass
diese Rahmenbedingungen der Europäischen
Union der europäischen Finanz- und
Geldpolitik letztendlich für die
innenpolitische Lage nicht das Maß der
Dinge für die nächste
konfliktentwicklung darstellt wir leben
ja in der multi-krisensituation wo es so
viele Krisen gibt dass man gar nicht
sagen kann was als nächstes ansteht wir
haben Corona wir haben Arbeitsmarkt
Probleme der Fachkräftemangel ist
elementar wir haben in Ostdeutschland
massive Demonstrationen gegen die
entlastungspolitik weil sie nicht
hinreichend ist wir haben soziale
Probleme und das Energieproblem das
Knappheit die Inflation das alles
zusammen und da wissen wir überhaupt
nicht wo der nächste
Herd sein wird der eine dynamische
Entwicklung entfaltet wir wissen nur
dass diese Koalition eigentlich
schneller lernen muss als es die
Konflikte erlauben das heißt man muss
mit der Welle laufen bzw vor der Welle
sich platzieren können und das sehen wir
Augenblick ein entscheidender Gedanke
für mich wir haben diesen
Koalitionsvertrag der Koalitionsvertrag
ist unter Bedingungen entwickelt worden
die nichts mit der gegenwärtigen
Konstellation zu tun insofern müsste man
eigentlich um Geländer und Leitplanken
für regieren zu haben zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt etwas Neues entwickelt und das
heißt ja das heißt nicht ein neuer
Koalition das wird man nicht können weil
der in der bestimmten Situation aber man
müsste drei vier Prinzipien wie man in
dieser
krisenkriegskonstellation handlungsfähig
ist sonst wird jede kleine oder große
Krise gleich zur zur Stresssituation zur
Frage von sein oder nicht sein dieser
Regierung neuer Koalitionsvertrag neu
Absprachen wäre das wichtig sich noch
sozusagen miteinander
sie haben jetzt ein Panorama der Krisen
entwickelt
umso zwingender ist die Logik das ist
drei Parteien sind und vielleicht nicht
nur zwei dann kommt hinzu natürlich kann
man das immer so sehen lächelnde Gesicht
wenn die wenn die FDP ein bisschen
kritisch ist in der
pandemiegeschichte mit den lockdowns
dann macht sie es für die AFD das ist
eine billige Disqualifizierung diese
Partei sie macht weil sie so überzeugt
ist
sie ist ich bin nicht deren Überzeugung
aber ich mag das nicht ständig wird ab
das ist nicht AFD das ist die
Überzeugung der FDP und die FDP gehört
in diese Regierung überhaupt wäre es mal
vernünftig vielleicht sogar in der Tabs
zu überlegen was das bedeutet eine
gelungene Revolution 1848 und eine
misslungene 1848 vielleicht hat das
heute ist das Besondere
dass die FDP die Partei ist die seit
Kriegsbeginn 24.2 am wenigsten an
Veränderung an Innovation entwickelt hat
und am wenigsten mit ihrer eigenen
Klientel in einen kreativen austauschen
für freisinnige Kräfte die Deutschland
dringend nötig hat aber sie will
diese
verhaltene Wilhelminismus zudem auch die
Begeisterung für Russland gehört aber
dies müsste man historisch auch
Fragen und die Wahlergebnisse geben der
FDP da ja nicht reicht dass sie sich
aber man verliert manchmal mein Mann was
vernünftiges tut aber ich wollte noch
mal was zum Thema Koalitionsvertrag
sagen also ich habe den ja gelesen und
deswegen kann ich sicher sagen dass da
eigentlich wenig drin stand was
irgendwie verbindlich war so und der der
tatsächlich verbindlichste teil und auch
der interessanteste war der zur
Windkraft und der ist natürlich
weiterhin hochaktuell
ansonsten stand aber ehrlich gesagt
nicht viel drin also immer nur
irgendwelche Absichtserklärungen aber
ohne jede Zahl also Kinder
Grundsicherung wie hoch die sein soll
wie viel Geld
wie viel das kosten soll ja eindeutig
widersprechen der Mindestlohn ist jetzt
gerade eingeführt worden dass Bürgergeld
ist im Prozess der Etablierung
also wirklich hunderte von Baustellen
und Prozesse
drin ja wie auch immer ist
wir können uns da auch gerne streiten
aber es war ein mehreren als bei über
100 Seiten lang und dafür war es
ziemlich dünn und deswegen aus dieser
Erfahrung würde ich davon abreiten jetzt
super neue Koalitionsverträge dazu
aufzählen kein neuer Koalitionsvertrag
sondern Prinzipien vereinbaren wie man
unter diesen Bedingungen gut regiert
aber das ist nicht ganz einfach
Prinzipien zu vereinbaren denn die
brauchen ja ein gemeinsames
Grundverständnis wir sind immer sehr
allgemein ja und jede Partei will ja
auch erkennbar
EU-Politik zu Kompromissen kommen wollen
dann gehört dazu sicherlich auch dass
wir nicht einfach so weiterwurstellen
können wie wir es bislang gemacht haben
da braucht also Reformen die können aber
nicht nur in die Richtung gehen Teil der
Altschulden wird vergemeinschaft und
ansonsten läuft alles so weiter sondern
da bräuchte man eine Regierung die sich
tatsächlich ein Konzept überlegt und das
dann auch als großes Mitgliedsland in
Europäischen Union so vorantreibt wenn
aber schon innerhalb der Regierungen
kein Konsens der deutschen Regierung
kein Konsens gefunden wird wie man den
eigentlich mit dem Problem umgehen
möchte ja den kann man nicht erwarten
dass wir diesen Konsens dann in der EU
finden und so gilt es eigentlich für
alle Politikbereiche also man war damals
sehr euphorisiert dass man so einen
Koalitionsvertrag überhaupt zustande
gebracht hat aber die Wirklichkeit
richtet sich ja nicht nach
Koalitionsverträgen sondern die Politik
muss ich nach der Wirklichkeit bleibt
man denn dann als Partei erkennbar wenn
man sagt es sind wir müssen ja doch wir
müssen zusammenarbeiten aber ich will ja
doch auch weil die FDP steht jetzt nicht
so gut den Ergebnissen und Umfrage wie
man sie will ja erkennbar bleiben ja
natürlich sie muss einfach ihren Weg
gehen aber der wichtigste Punkt den
haben sie gesagt der
Koalitionsvertrag hat nichts mit der
Wirklichkeit zu tun die nachher
eingetreten ist und da verlangen wir von
dieser Regierung unglaublich viel es ist
ganz klar wenn vier Leute wie wir
zusammensitzen unterkundigen Führung von
ihnen dann sind wir eigentlich die
Regierung die jetzt bräuchte also ganz
klar jeder Bürger bezahlen ja warum ist
die Regierung nicht wie die oder das ja
genau wir wissens und das ist das müssen
wir ein bisschen relativieren vor den
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern dass diese
Regierung ich habe es gesagt tastet dass
das ist so gewaltig was über sie
hereingebrochen ist aber sie muss
entscheiden
nach 16 Jahren in denen die Kanzlerin
ich weiß gar nicht ob sie gegeben hat
ist Phantom könnte es gewesen die
politische das politische Licht so
runter gedimmt hat Mann am Schluss sich
nicht mehr sah und wir Medien haben es
mitgemacht da fand Debatte nicht statt
die heute einholt nicht nur nicht nur
das Gas auch die ganze digitale
Ausrüstung Deutschlands die Abhängigkeit
von China habe ich schon gesagt das
müssen die auch noch aufarbeiten also
kritisieren wir sie aber mit diesem
Grund
Verständnis mit diesem Grund zur Partie
die es in der Demokratie braucht damit
jemand mal seine Arbeit tun kann okay
das heißt wenn man nach vorne schauen
das wäre ja Plädoyer dafür dass die
empfampel hält was denken Sie Herr
Schröder gibt es Punkt wo sie sagen
jetzt auch nach dieser Geschichte die
hält jetzt noch mal besser zusammen was
wäre da ihre Prognose naja das
grundlegende Fundament dieser Ampel ist
ja die Unfähigkeit der Union in der
gegenwärtigen Situation ihre
Vergangenheit aufzuarbeiten sich so
aufzustellen dass sie attraktiv ist dass
sie in eigenen Beitrag leisten kann wenn
man merkt sieht hat man den Eindruck
Engagements das und abends das ist
eigentlich niemand der dieses Land
stärker als die SPD das ist aber
normaler Mechanismus weil die
Berichterstattung über die Regierung ist
natürlich immer an dem Punkt ansetzen
was die alles falsch machen und wo sie
in die Irre laufen und wo sie nicht gut
regieren insofern ist es glaube ich eine
Momentaufnahme die wir haben aber was
die Festigkeit dieser Regierung
garantiert ist glaube ich schon das
gemeinsame Bemühen in dieser
außerordentlich schwierigen Zeit einen
Weg zu finden die Dinge so zu ordnen
dass am Ende für Gesellschaft für
Wirtschaft die Dinge funktionieren
da ist Scholz insofern die richtige
Persönlichkeit weil er ein
Langstreckenläufer ist weil er die Dinge
von hinten anschaut was kommt raus da
ist er Merkel Schüler und er ist jemand
der mit Besonnenheit die Dinge angeht
also ich glaube das ist schon eine ganz
gute Grundlage und jemand der eben nicht
nach den Umfragewerten sondern der
schaut was kann man wie machen und er
weiß er muss diesen Laden zusammenhalten
und dafür kann er nicht laufen basta
sagen und laufend irgendwelche
Kompetenzen vorgeben die die anderen
abarbeiten müssen sondern er muss im
Gespräch sondern esperater er ist
Verhandler und er muss hin und wieder so
starken Druck ausüben dass die Richtung
stimmt ich wollte nur sagen doch noch
mal zu Umfragen was eben der CDU sehr zu
denken geben sollte ist dass sie zwar
als Partei gute Umfragewerte haben aber
dass sie Umfragewerte für März so
schlecht sind der liegt ja weit hinter
Scholz und das ist natürlich keine Basis
auch nicht die für die FDP jetzt zu
sagen okay wir versuchen irgendwie mit
dieser CDU zu koalieren wenn sie gar
keinen Führer haben der beim Wahlvolk
ankommt
[Musik]
die einzige Figur die nichts mit den
Materialen zu tun hat und die kommt
nicht an er ist eigentlich eine
glückssituation er ist der jüngste
rein vom der Verdorbenheit durch diese
Merkel stillhalte Jahre ist der unbelegt
aber er ist aus der Zeit gefallen
irgendwo greift das nicht wobei es
wahrscheinlich leichter ist die sie
haben ja in der SPD auch so eine
Vergangenheit zu beantworten die waren
ja dabei also
Holz durch Handeln die Sache zu
bearbeiten als jemanden der regiert
nicht der soll das nur durch quasi reden
diskutieren
selbstkritisch sein das sehr schwierig
also eine gewisse Chance besteht jetzt
sicherlich darin dass jetzt glaube ich
ein Jahr lang erstmal keine größeren
wichtigen Wahlen anstehen das heißt man
kann dann auch erstmal Entscheidungen
treffen die kurzfristig sind in den
nächsten Monaten ja aber die grüne
nächste große ist Bayern oder die ist
noch einiges in Berlin hinaus ja gut
aber
ja da glaube ich wird es ist eines
das kann natürlich dann auch erstmal
also ein Teil des adventismus den wir in
den vergangenen Monaten erlebt haben in
der Politik war sicherlich auch der
niedersachsenwahl geschuldet dass man da
vorher möglichst harte Kante zeigen
wollte und das ist jetzt abgeräumt und
möglicherweise ist jetzt auch die
Kompromissfähigkeit innerhalb der drei
Parteien etwas größer als noch vor dem
Vergangenen Wahlabend bei den bei allen
Parteien ist es so bei der SPD und den
Grünen der ist der Parteivorsitz eben
anders als die also hier ist der Kanzler
ist nicht der
Parteivorsitzende und bei den Grünen ist
es auch so dass der Vizekanzler nicht
der Parteivorsitzende nur bei Lindner
ist irgendwie alles zusammen ist das
glücklich eigentlich das ist nicht gut
für diese Partei weil diese Partei hat
zu wenig Varianz hat zu wenig Pluralität
hat zu wenig Fähigkeit mit
unterschiedlichen Ideen auch so ein
Ideenwettbewerb innerhalb des eigenen
Lagers zu gestalten diese Engführung die
diese Partei erlitten hat seit
Westerwelle wenn man so will die kommt
dieser Partei am Ende nur Ding zugute
und man sieht das ja auch sie
funktioniert halbwegs auf Bundesebene
aber in den Ländern funktioniert sie
schon nicht mehr draußen und dieser
Junge Lindner hat sie eingeführt er hat
gigantische Leistung und dann ist das
muss man natürlich sehen sie haben diese
Leistung und wie soll ich sagen früher
hieß das immer du musst den
Parteivorsitz haben es war bei schön
oder auch noch so danke sagt du musst
den Parteivorsitz haben
ich also sie sehen und es ist
interessant die besten Ratschläge
kriegen die Parteien immer aus den
anderen Parteien
flackert ist etwas hinter uns das ist
kein Gewitter in Berlin aber wir haben
irgendwie ab und zu sie sehen mal so ein
paar technische Probleme
also ich sehe dass sie eigentlich alle
sehr positiv sind nach diesem nach
dieser Entscheidung das ist nicht so
negativ sehen oder Herr groß habe ich
sie da falsch verstanden
das war jetzt erstmal nur eine Atempause
aber ist weiterhin völlig offen wie der
energiepolitische Kurs dieser
Bundesregierung aussieht und das ist für
die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung kein
gutes Zeichen denn allein die
Unsicherheit macht eben auch jetzt
Investitionsentscheidungen schwierig
macht es auch den Märkten schwer zu
wittern jawohl könnte denn der ist neue
normalen Niveau bei den Energiepreisen
liegen wir bauen eine Brücke nach der
anderen aber wir wissen gar nicht wo das
andere Ufer ist und das ist eben keine
überzeugende Politik wir können uns
nicht mit lauter entlastungsprogramm
jetzt hier durch hangeln wir brauchen
jetzt strategische Entscheidungen und
glauben sie ganz kurz nur glauben Sie
dass die Schuldenbremse abgeräumt werden
muss als Ökonom nein glaube ich nicht
allerdings materiell ist jetzt erstmal
außer Kraft gesetzt kann man sagen es
hätte sonst noch schlimmer kommen können
weil sonst die ausgabenwünsche über alle
Grenzen gestiegen wären aber auf dem
Feld hat man sich bislang auch immer
Gedanken Fuß gemacht indem man Probleme
mit Geld zugeworfen hat aber das ist
auch keine Dauerlösung okay vielen Dank
Herr kurz herr Meyer Herr Schröder und
Frau Hermann für die Diskussion
entschuldigen Sie dieses Flackern im
Hintergrund das ja wir versuchen das zu
lösen vielen dank ihnen aber fürs
zuschauen jetzt geht es weiter mit
Phoenix der Tag und morgen schauen wir
mal nach China wir haben es ja schon
heute angesprochen und fragen uns halt
eben wie gefährlich diese Abhängigkeit
von China ist wir schummeln sie dabei
sind bis dann tschüss
[Musik]